talking about growing up in South Africa
he was born to a black mom and a white
dad from Switzerland during the
apartheid era or as Trevor says apart
apart hate when those relationships were
illegal in South Africa today his story
is really resonating with high school
students in Newark New Jersey why
because Noah's best-selling audio book
born a crime stories from a South
African childhood was chosen for New
York's first citywide school listening
club this is big is part of audibles
project listen up the program provides
free audible memberships and tablets to
all Newark high school students and
their teachers so we asked a few
students the other day how Noah story
inspired them if you talked about people
from the gutter like to get out together
but instead he wanted to transform it
and I feel like that just spoke so much
to me says I want to transform this
where it's a better place no matter what
I go through no matter when I'm facing
the matter what live brought to me no
matter what challenges or trials I can
make it look for Trevor is today he came
from literally being born a crime and
he's this successful person here who
didn't let his hardships affect who he
became in the future Wow Trevor Noah
joins us at the table with your heart
intact
good to see you Trevor we want to talk
about the book and the project cuz the
audible book is fantastic
but I really want to get your take on
what's happened today because you've
been talking about it all week right
right and for the past week what do you
what do you make of what's happen I'm
excited I mean you know this I think
this development in North Korea is
really huge for the world I think people
have to take this opportunity to not
hate on Donald Trump and go hey he took
a step he took a step forward towards
peace and if anything he furthered
Obama's goal that's what Obama said he
would do he said he would talk to
America's enemies not just men he was
criticized for it yeah he was and I
think it's really great that Donald
Trump said hey man that's that's a good
idea I'm gonna go up there and I'm gonna
do that I'm gonna speak to our enemies
and he may have surprised South Korea by
stopping you know the military exercises
on the border but you know clearly this
is part of a larger plan and then I
guess if Obama was also gonna do it then
there's some thinking behind this so
it's an exciting time we'll see where it
takes the world conversations just
beginning let's talk about your book
though Trevor this is if we read the
book he was here last time you talked
about the
but when I hear you talk about it an
audio I really you paint such a vivid
picture that I really feel like you're
taking me there but you start with this
- my mother my first fan thank you for
making me a man right that gave me
goosebumps whenever it's a love letter
to your mom it genuinely isn't here's
the thing I realize every day that I'm a
product of a person who was greater than
myself who brought me here and one of
the biggest gifts my mother gave me was
an opportunity to become a man you know
you want to be a man but you have to be
created you know you have to be taught
you have to be nurtured and I was really
lucky and telling the story that I
discovered that my mother was really the
hero of my story I always thought it was
me but I was just her punk-ass sidekick
I've accepted that I'm glad that the
story resonated with people yeah it's a
story that is international regardless
of where you're from so what was the
idea behind bringing these audiobooks to
these Newark city students well you know
what I've loved about this collaboration
with audible was we had met so many kids
who said to me hey I I love stories but
I'm not a great reader or there was one
kid who came up to me he said to me
straight he said yo as a young black man
some of my friends are gonna laugh at me
if they find me reading the book but I
love your story and he was like is there
another way I can I can get into your
story and I said well listen to it them
yeah no one knows what you're listening
to just get into the story and and what
I loved is seeing how different people
connect with a story when it is spoken
to them I've always been a storyteller I
come from a culture of storytellers and
so to have my book as part of the
curriculum but as an audiobook there's a
completely different way for for
learners to learn not just about my
story but also about South Africa story
a story of belonging a story of
segregation a story of overcoming a lot
of those obstacles what's it like
hearing the students react to your book
that way I'm always home good I'm
genuinely always humbled because I never
thought that my story would connect with
as many people as it did you know I
genuinely didn't because my your story's
always your story you go like I live in
my world I think to myself I'm
struggling with my issues yeah and then
you realize we all deal with issues of
belonging we all deal with issues of
self-doubt we all deal with obstacles in
our lives and they may be different
depending on where you're from but
there's always something that prevents
you from getting to where
you want to go and I think overcoming
that is a universal story that we can
all relate to and the relationship with
somebody you love and your family is
another that is universal and at the
heart of a to Trevor I think everybody
wants to belong and everybody wants to
be loved and when you listen to the book
it says also performed by Trevor right
because you really do act it out in some
ways you imitate your mom right
imitating Madiba Nelson Mandela you
metate the people that come into your
life and I wonder what that experience
was like for you did it change how you
even thought about your life in your
story it did because it forced me to
visualize everything so when you're
writing a book you're in the words you
see the words and you and you think
through it in a different way when
you're when you're performing the
audiobook I think the reason this became
the biggest selling audio book on
audible was because I I poured my heart
and soul into it you know I didn't go
into the studio and go let's bang this
out I spent hours and hours going back
over weeks let's let's do it let's let's
perform it let's live it and I
remembered each person in such a vivid
way because I had to embody them for the
story which I loved doing anyway yeah
you know so so in my head I would think
what was Nelson Mandela doing what was
he saying you know when he is making
these speeches what was my mother doing
what was she saying and it's eight hours
- it's eight hours but you know you it's
turned into a comedy routine but when
you think about being born a crime how
times your mom would literally have to
drop your hand and not claim you that
had to be very painful for you to sort
of work through all of that especially
when you get older and you know what
that really means you know what's funny
is it wasn't painful working through it
aha
it was I think it would galvanized the
feeling I had for my mother knowing that
she had to work through that because as
a child you only know your reality yeah
I was with my parents or I didn't know
that my mom was letting go of my hand
for a reason I was like yeah she's just
tired of holding my hand that happens
it's life I get it yeah you know and
then and then you get to this place
where you go wow that's what my parents
shielded me from and it's no easy thing
reading eight straight hours right but
you're gonna see your mother on this is
now gonna be made to film your book
right what's right that's gonna be like
having her turned into a character well
I'm really lucky because it took me a
while to think of who would play the
role and Lupita Nyong'o was gracious
enough to say hey
I'm reading a book right now she was on
the film set of Black Panther and she
called me and she said I hope you know
that I'm playing your mom and I was like
oh but of course yeah there's an African
woman who's beautiful leaves in herself
who represents so much of not just the
country but the culture but also she's
she's she's a box breaker you know when
you look at Lupita you go she's not what
you think she is world is playing
different worlds I don't know who do you
want you know I would love to play me
but I'm decades too old so I'm gonna
have to find like a little Trevor no
look Trevor congratulations thank you so
much thank you you're doing great on the
show we use a lot of your stuff dude
yeah I appreciate that we use a lot of
your stuff that